ما يجوز أن نقول: فلكي يتوقع أمطار أو برد أو حر
احنا نلبس الأبيض، ونشغّل المكيّف
ونشتري الآيسكريم، ونشلّق الجح
وننتهي ونضف مشالحنا والفراء والدفايات
قبل الـ 21 يونيو تقريبًا بشهرين
إذن ليش إذا بدأ الصيف العالمي 21 يونيو، يقولون...
طيب الأيام اللي قبل وصلنا 42، 43 وصيف
هذا أيش هو تسخين؟! تسخين للصيف
صدق
عام 20000 سيلحق الهجري الميلادي باليوم وبالشهر وبالسنة
هذا الرقم المميز والتاريخ المميز
إن أردت أن تتزوج أبو عمر بالتاريخ هذا
أهلًا، هذا فنجان من ثمانية
وأنا عبدالرحمن أبو مالح
هذه الحلقة عن التغيّر المناخي
فيه ناس تقول: أنه كذب، ومعظم العلماء يقولون: أنه حقيقة
وإن لم نتدارك الوضع؛ فالعالم سيتغير تغيّرًا لم تعشه البشرية من قبل
هذه الحلقة عن هذا الموضوع
مع ضيفي الدكتور «عبدالله المسند»
الحاصل على الدكتوراة في التغيّر المناخي
والأستاذ في المناخ في جامعة القصيم سابقًا
أما الآن؛ لنبدأ
أنا إذا رحت برّا، مثلًا لندن وللا في أمريكا وللا في أي مكان
تطبيق الطقس بالنسبة لي أساسي
أكيد
وأعتمد عليه
هو يقول لك: الساعة 5:41 بينزل مطر لمدة عشرين دقيقة
وفعلًا 5:00 ينزل مطر، ويقول لك بنسبة كم
في السعودية التطبيق حتى وهو مطر يكتب لك مشمس
ما له أي علاقة باللي يحصل
فما أدري إذا التطبيقات مشكلة
حتى أحيانًا هيئة الأرصاد أو الدفاع المدني
الدفاع المدني هو اللي يرسل رسائل
يرسل: أن بتنزل أمطار خلال هذا الأسبوع
في منطقة الرياض وضواحيها وغيره
ويمكن ما ينزل
وصدق هم يقولونه
هل هم عندهم تقنيات ماهي عندنا؟
وللا عندهم معرفة ماهي عندنا؟
وللا التطبيقات حقتنا ما تضبط وللا أيش المشكلة؟
جميل، بالنسبة لوصفك أنه 100% أو بالدقيقة
طبعًا أشعر أن فيها مبالغة
لا يمكن حتى في مواطن الطقس المعتاد
وخاصةً غرب أوربا والمناطق الاستوائية
الطقس عندهم اليومي رتيب
مثل لو أقول لك: بكرة ستشرق الشمس في الرياض
100% دون أي قزعة أو سحابة، لماذا؟
لأن هذا جوّنا عبارة عن شمس وسماء صافية وصحو
وهذه طبيعة مناخنا الصحراوي
طبيعة مناخهم المطري سواءً كانوا في المناطق الاستوائية
أو مناطق مثل بالذات غرب أوربا
هنا التطبيقات تصيد النفس
النماذج التي تتوقع التقلبات الطقسية تصيد النفس
ليس لأن تطبيقاتهم أفضل من تطبيقاتنا
كل ما بين أيدينا؛ منهم
كل النماذج؛ منهم
كل النماذج اللي احنا نشتغل فيها
بما فيها المركز الوطني للأرصاد
هي مخرجات غربية على وجه التحديد
فالمشكلة تكمن أن نظامنا الصحراوي ومناخنا الصحراوي
من الصعب التنبؤ فيه
نظرًا إلى أن هناك مزاحمة من أكثر من كتلة هوائية
جافة ورطبة، حارة وباردة
أربع كتل جوية يتصادمن فوق شبه الجزيرة العربية
ومنها المملكة العربية السعودية
من هنا يصعب على الإنسان وعلى أيضًا الكمبيوتر الخارق
على وجه التحديد بعنصر المطر أن يتنبأ بنسبة كبيرة جدًّا
من هنا جاءت دعوتي المتكررة
يا أيها المشتغلون بعلم الطقس والمناخ، أيها المتنبئون
رفقًا بالجمهور وبالمشاهدين وبالمتابعين
الذين تعطونهم وتقدمون لهم هذه الخرائط الملونة
التي تتوقع الحالات المطرية
التي بقي عليها ستين يوما، تسعين يوما
وأكثر من 4 أشهر أحيانًا
ثم يتعلق الجمهور، وأحيانًا حتى الجهات ذات العلاقة
تتعلق بهذه التوقعات التي ربما تشير إلى أن الموسم القادم
موسم خصب وموسم أمطار
أو ربما موسم قحط حار أو بارد
ومن ثم نتفاجأ أن النتيجة النهائية ربما المصداقية 5%
لأن المدى بعيد والمسافة بعيدة
ولا تسحبوا أنظمة أوربا أو أنظمة المناطق الوسطى
على أنظمة المناطق ذات الضغط الجوي المرتفع
كالمملكة العربية السعودية أو منطقة الشرق الأوسط
من هنا تأتي المشكلة
فأطمئن التطبيقات الموجودة وهي بالعشرات بجوالاتنا وأجهزتنا
هي نفسها التطبيقات التي خارج السعودية
لذلك، أقتصر غالبًا في التنبؤات عندما كنت تنبأ
وللا الآن توقفنا التزامًا لنظام الأرصاد
الذي بقي عليه اصدار التصاريح
عندما كنت أتنبأ واكتب هذا في حساباتي في وسائل التواصل
لا تتجاوز ثلاثة أيام، أو خمسة أيام إذا كان النماذج
الأمريكي والأوربي والألماني والبريطاني والكوري
إذا كانوا قد أجمعوا على أن هذه الحالة قوية
وأيضًا تكرر في أكثر من يوم
والمخرجات للنموذج جالسة تؤكد
أن الأمطار ستكون في منطقة الرياض على سبيل المثال
هنا ممكن أُبشر مع الحذر
ممكن أبشر للجمهور مع الحذر في خمسة أيام
وهذا قليل جدًّا
وبنسبة كم تكون دقيقة؟
خمسة أيام ما تصل ولا 50%
والدليل على ذلك، أنا أخاطب الجمهور
إذا أنتم ما أنتم مصدقين؛ خذوا التنبؤ الموجود في أي نموذج
وليكن مثلًا البريطاني وهو قريب ودقيق
خذ التنبؤ حق اليوم صوّره؛ ثم تنبؤ بكرة وبعده للأيام القادمة
سوف تجد أن الأمطار مرة يضعها على الرياض
مرة يسحبه على الأحساء، مرة يرفعه لحفر الباطن
ونحن ما نلومه
معقد جدًّا موضوع التنبؤ
وأكبر وأعقد وأغلى الكمبيوترات في العالم
ليست لوكالة الفضاء الأمريكية «ناسا»
وليست لوكالات الاستخبارات الأمريكية
وليست للأطباء، وليست لسوق وأسواق الأسهم
أكبر الكمبيوترات هي للتنبؤات الجوية
تعادل تقريبًا ثلاث تريلات مصفوفة مع بعض
التبريد من فوق إلى تحت، من جميع الجهات
نظرًا للاحترار الشديد للمعالج
ويعطيك المخرج أربع مرات في اليوم
أو مرتين في اليوم كل 12 ساعة
لأنه جالس آخذ لك الكوكب الأرض كله
وأي تأثير أو أثر في اليابان؛ راح يدفه على آسيا
وآسيا تدفه على منطقة الشرق الأوسط
بمعنى أن إذا وطّيت شوكة أو ما شابه ذلك
الجهاز العصبي عندك كله ينتفض
مع أن الأثر فقط في إصبع بسيط جدًّا
الكرة الأرضية عندها الجهاز العصبي هذا
لدرجة أن لو تم تلويث منطقة بسيطة في خليج البنغال
تأثرت معظم البحار
ولو تم حصول عاصفة غبارية في الصحراء الكبرى؛ يتأثر الأمازون
لأنها كوكب واحد، وحي وحيوي
من هنا تأتي مسألة التوقعات المناخية
وأختم بآخر تعليق دراسي قبل تقريبًا ثلاث أسابيع
عندما علّقت الدراسة في مكة من خلال مركز الأرصاد السعودي
التنبؤات لأقل من 24 ساعة مو يوم!
وعُلّقت الدراسة، أنا كنت هناك في مكة
الأجواء صافية، صحوة
فما استطاع مركز وليس شخص أو هاوي
أن يأتي بنسبة كبيرة من الثقة
وما تغيرت الأجواء إلا تقريبًا في فترة المساء
وعُلقت الدراسة يومين الأحد، والأسبوع القادم الأحد
وكانت النتيجة...
أنا أقول هذا، مو تقليل بمركز الأرصاد
بقدر ما أقول أن الموضوع صعب ومعقد عندنا وعند غيرنا
لكن عندنا أشد بحكم أننا في مناخ صحراوي، التذبذب فيه كبير جدًّا
سنة من السنوات ممكن تسقط عليك هنا في الوسطى
350 - 400 -وإن كان قليل- مليمتر في السنة، في الموسم
والسنة ما يجيك إلا ثلاثين
لو افترضنا أن راتبك أبو عمر 20 ألف مثلًا في الشهر
تخيل مرة 100 ألف ومرة 1500، كيف تبي تتصرف؟
صح
تتذبذب كبير جدًّا
بينما لو كنت تشتغل مثلًا في أوربا، راتبك تراوح ما بين 18 - 22
شوفت تذبذب بسيط جدًّا
وما ذاك إلا بسبب طبيعة الموقع الفلكي الذي نحن فيه
الآن أنا أتوقع - هذا تحليلي للفكرة- أن التطبيقات
احنا في الأخير نستخدم مثلًا تطبيق الطقس
الموجود في الآيفون أو في أي جوال ثاني
وأن التطبيقات تأخذ من مراكز البيانات
فهي نفسها يمكن تسوي تحليل بسيط أو قراءة بناءً على التاريخ
لكن قلت يمكن أن الخلل من...
فأتوقع أنهم يأخذون من مراكز الأرصاد السعودية أو في الجزيرة العربية
ومن ثم لضعف النتائج اللي تطلع من عندنا
تصير التطبيقات ما تقدر تقيس شيء
نحن الآن في الرياض، يأخذ التطبيق من مركز الأرصاد
الموجود في المطار
والمطارات اللي عندنا حوالي سبعة وعشرين مطار مدني
هي التي تطلع عندك بالتطبيق
ولكن عندما تذهب مثلًا إلى «رماح» وللا تذهب إلى وسط «الدهنة»
ما في محطات أرصاد
تأتيك البيانات من الأقمار الصناعية، كافة عناصر المناخ
الضغط الجوي، ويأتيك الرياح واتجاهه
سرعة الرياح، وهبات الرياح، ونسبة الأمطار
الشروق والغروب، الشغلات الفلكية
فكل التفاصيل اللي تجدها في الرياض أو في جدة أو في الدمام
تجدها في أي بقعة في العالم سواءً فوق المحيط أو فوق الربع الخالي
فهذه من معطيات الأقمار الصناعية بشغلات معقدة
تستأنس طبعًا بالمحطات الموجودة في الأرض
وبالمناسبة حتى ما أُحبط المتابع لهذه التطبيقات
درجة الحرارة نسبة الوثوقية فيها عالية
عندما أقول لك بعد أسبوعين ستنخفض درجة الحرارة في الرياض
نظرًا لوجود كتلة هوائية باردة سوف تتغلغل إلى وسط المنطقة
غالبًأ نسبة الوثوقية فيها عالية جدًّا
نسبة من كم؟
إذا تحدثنا على أيام، بضعة أيام، ثلاثة أو خمسة أيام
قد تصل إلى 85% أو 90% فتعتمد عليها
عندك طلعة، عندك احتفال في الخارج؛ اعتمد على المخرجات
وممكن إلى أسبوع، عشرة أيام؛ ما عندك أي مشكلة
المشكلة في الأمطار
الأمطار والغبار وللا بس الأمطار؟
لا، المشكلة في الأمطار
الغبار يأتي بعده، غالبًا مع الأمطار
لأن بعض السحب تثير الغبار
فإذا عندكم مثلًا مناسبة في الخارج
وأنا عندي توقعات أن الرياض
سيكون هناك منخفض جوّي متوسطي أو منخفض السوداني
راح يؤثر على المنطقة، ويكون فيه أمطار
النماذج تعطيك التوقع وتعطيك أيضًا سرعة الرياح واتجاه الرياح
وتعطيك توقعات نسبة إثارة الغبار
وإن كانت أيضًا فيها تعقيد، ليست كمعرفة درجة الحرارة
أو معرفة درجة الرطوبة أو نقطة الندى أو بقية العناصر
لذلك إذا كان هناك سحب حتى لو ما كان فيه أمطار
فقط وجود السحب؛ أحيانًا الرياح الهابطة التي تضرب الأرض
وتنزل من السحب الركامية؛ تثير الغبار في المنطقة المستهدفة
ومن ثم يتجه الغبار في كل الاتجاهات
بالضبط بشكل دائري
طيب ليش مراكز الأرصاد في المطارات؟
في كل العالم لا يمكن أن تنشئ مطار إلا مقرون بمحطة أرصاد
لأن الطيران علاقته بالأجواء والتقلبات الجوية علاقة قوية جدًّا
ولا يمكن الطيار أن يقلع بالطائرة حتى يقرأ التقرير الميثولوجي
والطيارين ومساعد الطيار، كلهم فاهمين في علوم الطقس
ربما أكثر من المتخصص في الأرصاد الجوية
بحكم أنه في الميدان
ويقرأ ليس فقط عناصر الطقس فوق سطح الأرض
وإنما في مستويات مختلفة، كيلو، كيلوين، خمسة، ستة
عشرة إلى إحدى عشر كيلو حيث تستقر الطائرة
كل هذه الطبقات يقرأها عند الإقلاع والهبوط
ويقرأ فقط طبقات الجو العليا ما بين المطارين
عندما يحلّق لمدة ساعة أو 14 أو 17 ساعة أيضًا
بل أن مقدمة الطائرة، لو تم فتح المقدمة
سوف تجد رادار «دوبلر» هذا الرادار جالس يمسح لك الطريق
لمسافة تصل إلى 250 كيلو
فهم يشوفون السحب
ولذلك أحيانًا تحصّل الطائرة الدولية مثبين المسار إلى المطار المستهدف
فجأة، وإذا كانت بالطائرة تميل إلى اليمين أو اليسار
تطالع من خلال النافذة إذا كنت في النهار
سوف تجد أنه جالس يتحاشى جبل بارز
عبارة عن سحب ركامية عظيمة جدًّا بارزة من بين السحب الطبقية
تطالع أحيانًا إلى 12، 13، 14 كيلو
هذا طبعًا ما يدخل الطيار مغامرة
فلا بد أن يتحاشاها، ثم يعود لمساره مرة أخرى
فالمحطات لابد أن تزرع وتبنى قبل أن يبدأ المطار
بل الذين يخططون لإقامة المطار
عندهم خلفية عن الموقع هذا، هل هو مناسب؟
لذلك لا تجد المطارات قريبة من السلاسل الجبلية
فإذا اضطروا إلى إقامة المطار قريبًا من السلاسل الجبلية
سيكون المطار هذا مزعج ومحرج للطيارين وأيضًا للركاب
بسبب الرياح التي تصطدم في الجبل أو التي تنزل من الجبل
أو الظروف المتباينة ما بين الوادي
أو الأماكن السهلية التي فيها المطار وما بين الجبل
فهناك تباين كبير بدرجة الحرارة وهذا يزعج الطيار
ما في تجانس في الهواء
فتجد أن المطارات موجودة في الأماكن المبسوطة
لذلك مطار أبها ومطار المدينة على وجه التحديد
دائمًا ينزعج الراكب من هاذين المطارين والله أعلم
ما مدى قدرتنا على معرفة تغيّر الفصول؟
تغيّر الفصول؟
إيه، الآن دخول فصل الشتاء، هل هي دقيقة؟
أيش اللي بيصير؟
يمكن الحين لأن صار فيه منع للناس
أنها تتكلم عن الطقس والمناخ؛ فهدأت
يقول خلاص العشرين يوم الجاية شديدة البرودة
الآن تغيّر الطقس، الأربعين يوم الجاية ما أدري أيش صاير
دخلنا المربعانية، طلعنا منها، رحنا ما دري وين
انتهى فصل الصيف؛ وتلقى نقعد شهرين قدام وما زال شديد الحرارة
فما مدى دقة تحديد الفصول في السعودية؟
الفصول الأربعة وكما تعلمنا ودرسنا على مستوى العالم
موجودة ولا تغيروا
وإذا تكلمت على مستوى العالم
العالم النصف الشمالي، عكسه النصف الجنوبي
خلينا بالشمالي، احنا شماليين
فصل الشتاء القادم أو الذي ننتظره يبدأ عالميًا في 21 ديسمبر
كل سنة ما يتغير
في كل العالم يدخل أو في النصف هذا؟
إيه نعم، 21 ديسمبر
هناك يدخل الصيف بالجنوب، بالشمال يدخل في 21 ديسمبر
الربيع يدخل في 21 مارس، 21 يونيو الصيف
و23 سبتمبر يدخل الخريف، انتهينا
لكن هذه التوزيع لا يمكن أنك تفصل لي ثوب لك وتلبسني إياه
ماهو مناسب لي أنا الثوب هذا؟
أنت أطول من، أسمن من، أقصر من
فأنا اقترحت، لأن أحيانًا الصيف يدخل في 21 يونيو
لكن نحن نلبس الأبيض ونشغّل المكيف
ونشتري الآيسكريم، ونشلّق الجح
وننتهي، ونضف مشالحنا والفراء والدفايات
قبل الـ 21 يونيو تقريبًا بشهرين
إذن ليش إذا بدأ الصيف العالمي 21 يونيو، يقولون...
طيب الأيام اللي قبل وصلنا إلى 42، 43 وصيف
هذا أيش هو تسخين؟! تسخين للصيف!
صدق
أنا أقول لهم بناءً على تتبع درجة الحرارة كمعيار للمملكة
واستثني بذلك الجنوب الغربي لأن له نظام خاص جبال «السروات»
بقية مناطق المملكة ممكن نقول
من مايو شهر خمسة يدخل الصيف عندنا
من مايو ويونيو، يوليو، أغسطس وسبتمبر
كم صارن؟ خمسة أشهر
بينما العالم، خاصةً الشماليين ما عندهم إلا ثلاثة أشهر
احنا فصل الصيف الحقيقة بناءً على التكييف
بناءً على درجة الحرارة، بناءً على إحساسنا وأكلنا ولبسنا
خمسة أشهر، من مايو إلى سبتمبر
الآن نحن في أكتوبر دخلنا فصل الخريف
بناءً على التقسيم المقترح من عندي
دخلنا فصل الخريف، عطيت الخريف فقط شهرين
الخريف عطيته أكتوبر وأيضًا نوفمبر
معليش خلك في الخريف
هل الخريف عندنا يختلف عن الخريف عندهم؟
عندهم تتساقط الأشجار
إيه، نعم
احنا ما يصير شيء
بعض الأشجار ممكن نخليها تتساقط
موجودة
أيش سمات الخريف في الجزيرة العربية؟
سمات الخريف عندنا وعندهم اعتدال الأجواء
وخروجنا من الأجواء الحارة الصيفية
ودخولنا إلى أجواء معتدلة وبداية الأمطار
النظام الخريفي إلى حدٍ ما
فأنا أعطيته أكتوبر ونوفمبر
إذا دخلنا 1 ديسمبر، بالمناسبة 1 ديسمبر تدخل المربعانية
على بعض الحسابات خاصةً حساب «ابن بسام»
1 ديسمبر يدخل الشتاء
حتى أرصاديًّا، 1 ديسمبر يدخل الشتاء
فأنا أعطيت الشتاء: ديسمبر ويناير وفبراير، ثلاثة أشهر
بناءً على درجة الحرارة
تاكل «حنيني» و«فريتس» والدفاية
وحطيبات وضوء وكشتات
ثلاثة أشهر تكفيكم وللا لا؟
مقبولة
خير وبركة
ثم الربيع أعطيته -طال عمرك- مارس وإبريل
شهر ثلاثة وأربعة هذا لفصل الربيع
والربيع حقيقةً ممكن أيضًا يدخل فيه جزء من فبراير
ليست هي المسألة حدّية وبالمسطرة، ولكن اجتهاد
التقسيم هذا أقرب للواقع ومتناغم مع لبسنا
مع التكييف أو التدفئة أو الأكل
لأن الشتاء له أكل غير الصيف
ما أدري أنت تأكل بالشتاء الآيسكريم، أبو عمر؟
لا، بس أكل عريكة طول السنة
تزداد في الشتاء
لذلك المناخ يتدخل في لبسنا
وفي أكلنا وشربنا وكشتاتنا وسياحتنا البرية
ونفسياتنا
وفي نفسياتنا ومزاجنا
الآن لو نسمع الرعد ويبدأ المطر يهطل
أنا أجزم كل موظفينك بيطلعون ويخلوننا
أولهم المصور، ليش؟
لأنهم يشرقون بالمطر، وحتى لو بيني وبينك خلاف
مبروك يا أبو عمر ما شاء الله على الخيرات
طيب أنا وإياك متخاصمين!
لا، تغيّرت النفسية
لكن خلّى الغبار يجي
وخل العواصف الغبارية تهب
أول ما أسوّي أنزّل الشتر وأغلق الستارة
ولا أخرج من البيت وأحاول أني أسوي لي جو خاص
عبر وسائل التواصل أو التلفزيون أو القراءة
الأجواء في الخارج ممرضة
وأيضًا تنرفز الواحد
وربما ارتفاع درجة الحرارة مع الغبار
يسبب أيضًا مزاج قابل للاشتعال
درجة الحرارة بالمناسبة...
لذلك حسب علمي لا توجد دراسة على الأقل سعودية
في محاولة كشف الجرائم بالذات الهوشات
والخناقات بالذات في الطرقات
واللي يتهاوشون على الملابق والشغلات هذه
بين الشتاء والصيف، هل فيه علاقة أو لا؟
فعلًا، أتوقع أن فيه علاقة واضحة
بس لو واحد يسوي دراسة بيكون رائع
الحين هذه فهمناها على واقعنا اليوم
بس قبل لا أروح للماضي، لأن ودي أعرف كيف كانت العرب
تقيس هذه التقلبات ويقرون المستقبل ويتنبؤون بالطقس
ودي أعرف أول شيء، أنت استثنيت جنوب غرب المملكة
إيه نعم
ليش الاستثناء؟
طبعًا المنطقة هذه منطقة سلسلة جبال «السروات» مرتفعة
من 1600 أو 1800 من جهة الطائف
خلينا نبدأ من الطائف إلى فيفاء في الجنوب
إلى الربوع، إلى الجبل الأسود، مرورًا بعسير ومرورًا بالباحة
هذه من الظلم أنها تدخل بمناخ السعودية
اللي دايم نقول حار صيفًا وبارد ممطر شتاءً
لذلك أستغرب الناس الذين عندهم صورة نمطية لمناخ المملكة
أنه فعلًا شديد الحرارة وشحيح الأمطار
عندما يشاهدون هذه المصايف الجميلة والرائعة نظرًا للارتفاع
كلما ارتفعت 150 متر؛ قلّت درجة الحرارة درجة واحدة
فإذا ارتفعنا إلى 3000 متر، سوف نعيش بأجواء تصل في الصيف
أتكلم في عز الصيف، إلى أجواء ثلاثينية
بحر الـ 30، وأحيانًا 29، 27
بينما تطل على تهامة أسفل منك
بيننا وبينهم  12 درجة مئوية
إضافةً إلى أن السحب تتشكل ما بعد منتصف النهار
بسبب الرطوبة القادمة من البحر الأحمر
ومن إثيوبيا وأجزاء من بحر العرب
تدفعها الرياح ممكن نقول الموسمية
ثم تصطدم بالجبال ثم تتشكل السحب
كنظام سنوي رتيب وجميل ورائع
وأتمنى بهذه المناسبة وأنا أقود السيارة ما بين الطائف والباحة
قريبًا من «بني سعد» و«ميسان»
أتأمل بتلك التلال الواسعة وغابات وأجواء جميلة ورائعة
أبو عمر هذه تشيلنا كلنا يا السعوديين
المنطقة مثل الباحة فقط أو عسير، ممكن تشيل كل السعوديين
لذلك أتمنى أن يتم الالتفات
لأن فيه معاناة عندنا في السعودية
ستة أشهر قلناها صيف
أتمنى أن يلتفت لهذه الهضاب
ما أتكلم تزاحمون المدن؟ لا
دعوا المدن، دعوا المزارع
لكن هناك مساحات جغرافية بينية
ما بين الباحة و«المندق» على سبيل المثال
ما بين الطائف و«ميسان» على سبيل المثال
هناك مساحات نستطيع إقامة فيها
أعتى وأرقى وأجمل الجامعات
مدن جامعية تعيش في أجواء سحب وأمطار
ما أقول كأنهم في أوربا، لأن أوربا في الصيف بالذات الجنوب
ومنها فرنسا والبرتقال وإسبانيا وإيطاليا واليونان ودول البلقان
أشد حرًا من الباحة ومن عسير ومن مرتفعات جيزان
فهذه المنطقة كوننا فقط نلتفت لها شهرين
متمثلة بإجازة العام الدراسي ومن ثم تبقى للهواء والشمس!
بودي الحقيقة أن تنتقل المدن حتى الصناعية
ربما يقول البعض التضرر شديد هناك وصعب
مو صعب، هناك من الهضاب الجاهزة لاستقبال مدن صناعية
وأقصد بالصناعية الخفيفة والغالية
صناعات على سبيل المثال الإلكترونيات
ما أتكلم عن صناعات سيارات وما شابه ذلك
أتكلم أيضًا على ملاعب رياضية
بحكم أن النشاط الرياضي هناك، ممكن تقيمه حتى عصرًا بالمناسبة
هنا معظم الأنشطة الرياضية تُقام بعد الصلاة العشاء أو المغرب
وما ذاك إلا بسبب درجة الحرارة
صحيح
وهناك الدراسة ممكن تكون الجامعية فصول حتى في الصيف
السياحة، استيطان الناس
ممكن بالذات المتقاعدين ممكن ينتقلون
من حفر الباطن، عنيزة، بريدة، حائل، الجوف، الرياض
تقاعد؛ اذهب إلى هذه الأجواء الجميلة
بالذات اللي خلاص ودّع أولاده وتزوجوا وانتهوا
ومو مرتبط بجامعات؛ اذهب إلى أماكن الاستيطان الدائم
وتحظى بأجواء جميلة ورائعة
إلا للي عندهم مشكلة في القلب صحيًّا
أو التنفس أحيانًا لأنها تكون في الضغط الجوي
يمكن هذه جبل «السودة» مرتفعات
أقل من ثلاثة كيلو إلى حدٍ ما مقبولة
مقبولة؟
مقبولة، إيه نعم
فيه عندنا الحين عسير من الأماكن اللي الآن عليها اهتمام
فيه قمم «السودة» المشروع الأخير
فنقول يا رب كثير من الاهتمام هذا
لأن فعلًا في الصيف أغلب العالم حر
بينما لو تروح الباحة، تروح عسير؛ الجو معتدل
جدًّا ورائع
عكس بقية العالم
الحين برجع لكيف كانوا العرب
ودي أعرف كيف كانوا يقيسون أو يتنبؤون بالطقس؟
قديمًا قبل التقنية
العرب ونظرًا لأن قدرهم الكوني
قد استوطنوا في مثل هذه الصحاري
فهم أكثر الناس تتبعًا للتقلبات الجوية
كما أن أصحاب الغابات والمواقع الباردة
يبارك بعضهم لبعض عندما تشرق الشمس
لأنهم محرومين من الشمس
بسبب كثافة السحب والأمطار والرطوبة
احنا لا، عندنا شغف لتتبع التقلبات الجوية
فمن الإمارات أنهم استطاعوا أن يستفيدوا من النجوم
التي الله سبحانه وتعالى مَنّ بها علينا
«وَعَلامَاتٍ وَبِالنَّجْمِ هُمْ يَهْتَدُونَ»
فاكتشفوا ثمانية وعشرين منزلة، ثمانية وعشرين نجم
هذا دليلهم وتقويمهم السنوي
فإذا خرج النجم الفلاني مثلًا، دخل الشتاء عندهم
وبدأت الأمطار أو بدأ البرد أو بدأ الحر
تقويمهم في السماء ومضبوط
أيضًا إذا دخل الشتاء؛ لا يعني ذلك الأمطار ستحضر
شحيحة أمطارنا، ولكن يتتبعون الرياح
الرياح عندما تكون جنوبية في موسم الأمطار
موسم الأمطار يبدأ عندنا تقريبًا من منتصف أكتوبر
من الآن تقريبًا، اليوم احنا في 12 أكتوبر
من منتصف أكتوبر ويمتد إلى نهاية شهر مايو
ولا يعني ذلك أن الأمطار طول الوقت
لكن هذه الفترة الزمنية لنزول الأمطار
فإذا كانت الرياح جنوبية؛ يستبشرون بها
سيما إذا أعقب هذه الرياح الجنوبية في وقت الأمطار
ظهور سحب لها دلالة، سحب «السمحاق»
سحب عالية جدًّا، غالبًا ليس لها ظل ولا تحجب أشعة الشمس
وكأنها ضباب بسيط يخفف من أشعة الشمس
فنسميها سحب «السمحاق» أو «السدى»
تأتي على هيئة طبقية وتُحدث للشمس هالة
ربما شفت الهالة حول الشمس
وأحيانًا تكون حول القمر في الليل
هذه يستبشرون خيرًا أن وراء «الأكمة» ما وراءها
وأن هذا منخفض جوي
طبعًا ما يفهمون ذلك الوقت المنخفض الجوي
أن هناك حالة مطرية قادمة، ما دليلكم؟
الرياح الجنوبية التي بدأت تتحرك من جنوبية إلى جنوبية غربية
معنى ذلك، أن هناك كأن مغناطيس يقوم بتحريك الرياح
مع عقارب الساعة، من شرق، جنوب شرق، جنوب، جنوب غرب، غرب
دلالةً على أن هناك منخفض جوي راح يتغلغل في أجواء المملكة
ويكون فيه اضطرابات جوية وعدم استقرار
لا يعني ذلك 100% سوف يأتي بأمطار
أحيانًا سحب فقط والأمطار تسقط في الأردن، الشام، العراق
ويجينا احنا فقط عدم استقرار جوي
وربما غبار وسحب، وأحيانًا لا
فيعلم الأوائل عن قرب سقوط الأمطار من خلال حركة الرياح
وخاصة البادية والرعاة والمزارعين
لأن أوصلتهم بالمناخ والربيع والكلى أكثر من غيرهم
أما علم الصيادين والبحارة فهو أدق وأعمق من أهل البر
لسبب بسيط، لأن ذيك فيها حياة أو موت
البحارة تحتاج إلى نوخذة وتحتاج إلى خبير
بالذات في موضوع الرياح
لأن الرياح هي التي تثير الأمواج وتشكّل الأمواج
ففيها حياة وموت، فلا بد أن تكون خبير وضليع
في إمارات تقلبات الطقس
حتى تنقذ نفسك من العواصف ومن حالات عدم الاستقرار
فهذه تقريبًا حالتين: الرياح والسحب السمحاقية
ما مدى دقتها وتعقيدها؟
هي مو معقدة كما تلاحظ، لكن كما ذكرت لك
لا يعني ذلك في بعض المناطق يسمونها «النداة»
عند غروب الشمس أو قبيل غروب الشمس
يكون فيه سحب «السمحاق» الخفيفة
تصطدم فيها الأشعاع الشمسية
وهي عبارة عن بلورات ثلجية على ارتفاعات عالية جدًّا
ربما تصل إلى 7، 8، 10 كيلو. فهي مثلّجة فوق
فالبلورات الثلجية تعمل عمل المنشور الزجاجي
فتظهر لنا ألوان، وكأنها عين أو دائرة، هذه يسمونها «النداة»
هذه تُبشر بقدوم المنخفض، لكن لا نجزم
ممكن يجيك المنخفض بس ما فيه أمطار
الله ما أمره أن تمطر وإنما عدم استقرار جوي
ورياح وغبار وسحب وأحيان برق ورعد، لكن ما تنزل الأمطار
والموضوع معقد «إِنَّ ٱللَّهَ عِندَهُۥ عِلْمُ ٱلسَّاعَةِ وَيُنَزِّلُ ٱلْغَيْثَ»
الموضوع معقد ولا يمكن أحد حتى في المناخات الرتيبة
أن يجزم بنزول المطر 100%
حتى في وضع ما يسمى بالاستمطار، والله أعلم
الحين أنت تقول الرياح، وأيش كمان اللي تأثر؟
والسحب السمحاقية هذه مؤشرات للأولين
ليش كانوا الأولين يقولون «لا جاء سهيل لا تأمن السيل»؟
أيش علاقة النجوم؟
النجوم عبارة عن تقويم
الموعد اللي بينك وبينك الساعة 6:00 صح وللا لا؟
ما يمكن تقول اللي جاب «عبدالله المسند»
هنا بالاستوديو الساعة 6:00، لا
الساعة 6:00 عبارة عن مؤشر زمني، متفقين أنا وإياك
هو إلا جاء بسيارته وبرجلينه ووصل
«سهيل» ما له علاقة بالموضوع
مثل الساعة
«الإكليل» «القلب» «الشولة» «الأبراج»
كلها ما لها علاقة في الموضوع
هذه نجوم عبارة عن شموس بعيدة عنا
ما في إلا نجم واحد هو الذي بإذنه تعالى
يؤثر على المناخ، بل على الحياة بأكملها، ألا وهو الشمس
الذي يبعد عنا 150 مليون كيلومتر
لكن بقية النجوم بعيدة جدًّا، ليس لها أثر
لا على النبات، ولا المناخ، ولا الإنسان، ولا الحيوان
وكل ما يقال في موضوع التخبيص المسمى بالتنجيم
ليس له علاقة، والفلكيون غير المسلمين وحتى الملاحدة
يضحكون على هؤلاء المنجمين
سواءً كانوا مسلمين أو غير مسلمين
ولكن الناس تبي تاكل عيش
النجوم مالها أي أثر على الإنسان؟
لا، وإنما أنا أتخذها كتقويم
فإذا طلع «سهيل» وهو نجم دري متوقّد يشع وهو متغير الألوان
يطلع في الجنوب الشرقي
ويبدأ على وجه التحديد في الوسطى
يبدأ الناس تشوفه قريبًا من 24 أغسطس
بعضهم قبل 20-18 أغسطس حسب موقعك
كلما اتجهت إلى الشمال
مثلًا الرياض يشاهدونه قبل القصيم
الأفلاج يشاهدونه قبل الرياض
شرورة يشاهدونه قبل الأفلاج
اليمن يشاهدونه قبل شرورة، بالشكل هذا
لأن «سهيل اليماني» سُمي بيماني
بحكم أنه في النصف الجنوبي من القبة السماوية
لذلك علماء الفلك قسموا القبة الفلكية إلى قسمين
جنوبي سموه يماني نسبةً لليمن، وشامي نسبةً للشام
كان عندنا تقويم الهجري الشمسي، صحيح؟
أيوة
كان هذا المعتمد أول عند العرب؟
ماذا تقصد بالعرب؟
اذكر حقبة معينة، قبل الإسلام، بعد الإسلام؟
قبل الإسلام، لأن بعد الإسلام صار القمري
الهجري القمري
العرب قبل الإسلام لا يتعاطون التقويم وما عندهم التقنية هذه
العرب عندهم عام الفيل
وعندهم عام كذا المعركة الفلانية
وما عندهم المسألة الرياضية الحسابية
ماهي موجودة، والدليل على ذلك
أن فيه اختلاف في ولادة
أكرم وأشرف وأشهر مخلوق محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
ما استطاعوا أنهم يحددون يوم معين
ترى بالمناسبة إلى عهدٍ قريب
حتى مع شيباننا، سنة الغرق، وسنة الهدم
عام الرمادة في عهد عمر
ما يتعاطون التقويم
بل أن خطابات عمر رضي الله عنه
مع تخوم الخلافة الإسلامية آنذاك بدون تاريخ
يقول لك مثلًا رمضان، شوال
طيب أنا ما أدري هو رمضان اللي فات ذا وللا اللي قبله
ما أدري لازم يكون فيه رقم
السنة 17-18 من الهجرة أو كذا
لذلك تم تأسيس التقويم نظرًا لأن العرب
ومن ثم صدر الإسلام، ما كان فيه تقويم يتعاطونه العرب
«والحكمة ضالة المؤمن أنى وجدها فهو أحق بها»
فأخذوا من الفرس شغلات كثيرة
فيما يتعلق بالدواوين وفيما يتعلق أيضًا بالتقويم
فاستخدموا التقويم الهجري القمري
استخدموا التقويم الهجري القمري، ولأن هذا التقويم شرعي
نتعبد الله بالتعاطي معه من أجل العبادة
الصيام والحج وأيضًا أمور تتعلق بالحداد
وأمور تتعلق بالمرأة وما شابه ذلك
لكن الأمور المتعلقة بالزراعة
ما يصلح أن أقول لك تزرع في 5 شوال البطيخ
أو خلينا نقول 1 رمضان، تزرع البطيخ أو تزرع القمح
1 رمضان مرة يأتي في الشتاء ومرة في الصيف
لأنه يدور على كامل السنة الشمسية خلال أربعة وثلاثين سنة
لذلك بالمناسبة رمضان القادم
والذي سوف يبدأ في 11 مارس بإذنه تعالى
سيكون أول رمضان يدخل الشتاء، آخر الشتاء
ثم بعد أيام من رمضان القادم، راح يدخل الربيع
لأن جزء منه في آخر الشتاء
وأول الربيع
أول الربيع
فسيزحف رمضان كل سنة بمعدل إحدى عشر يوم
يُبكّر ويزحف القهقري بالوراء
شوف بيدخل مارس في 11
السنة اللي بعده، اخصم إحدى عشر يوم
يبي يدخل في 1 مارس، ثم يدخل في فبراير
يرجع بالشكل هذا
راح نعيش بإذنه تعالى، ثمان سنوات رمضان في الشتاء
وراح نصوم إن شاء الله عام 1450 و1452
في عز الشتاء في ديسمبر ويناير
بينما الحج سيدخل بإذنه تعالى في بداية الصيف ونهاية الربيع
يبدأ يدخل في الربيع، سيمكث في الربيع تسع سنوات
ومن أراد أن يحج في الشتاء يصبر إلى عام 1457-1458
عشان يدخل  في عز الشتاء في ديسمبر في يناير
وإلا إحصائيًّا أو وفقًا للفصول
راح يدخل الحج في الشتاء تقريبًا عام 1454
كان قبل التقويم الهجري كان عندهم الأشهر، صح؟
الأشهر موجودة قبل الإسلام
هي نفسها اللي اعتمدت؟
نعم اعتمدت، ما تغيرت
عندهم ذو الحجة وذو القعدة وما تغيرت
يوم اعتمد التقويم الهجري القمري
كان المزارعين يستخدمون التقويم الهجري الشمسي؟
اللي هو الميزان و... اللي هو الأبراج؟
نعم الأبراج هذه تعادل الشهور
برج «الميزان» و«الأسد» و«السنبلة» و«العذراء» والشغلات هذه
هذه أبراج في السماء
تجلس الشمس في كل برج 30-31 يوم
وهي المعمول فيها خاصةً في العراق وفي الشام
إلى الآن بالمناسبة هذا التقييم مفعّل آنذاك
وأيضًا المسلمين الذين يتحرجون من التقويم الميلادي
وللا ممكن نسميه الشمسي الميلادي
ذهبوا إلى تقويم شمسي يعتمد على البروج
بل وهناك تقويم شمسي تشوفه أنت بتقويم «أم القرى»
«هـ.ش» هجري شمسي بتقويم «أم القرى»
وبدأ الحساب من هجرة النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
بالقمري وبالشمسي جميع
لكن وصلنا بالقمري 1445
الهجري وصلنا الآن تقريبًا 1402 أو كذا
ليش تأخر هذا؟ لأن هذا طول سنته 365 يوم
بينما القمري طول سنته 354 يوم
لذلك من المفارقات ومن الطرائف
عام 20000 كم باقي عليه؟
باقي عليه حوالي 19 ألف
عام 20000 سيلحق الهجري الميلادي
وراح نكتب التاريخ 20000/1 و 20000
أنا نسيت طبعًا فيه كسور
ثم سويت حسبة وطلّعت متى يوافق الهجري الميلادي
باليوم وبالشهر وبالسنة
هذا الرقم المميز والتاريخ المميز
إن أردت أن تتزوج أبو عمر بالتاريخ هذا
اكتبه بوصيتك، وتناقله أحفادك وبعد 19 ألف سنة
لأنه فعلًا تاريخ مميز هذا
يكون سبّاق فيه، الله المستعان
وبعد هذا بالمناسبة؛ يسبق الهجري ويكون أكثر
يسبق الهجري الميلادي، ويكون الميلادي أقل رقم
عجيب والله
بقفل موضوع زمان
هل كان فيه ناس معينة هي اللي عندها علم معين
بقدرتهم على تنبؤ بالطقس؟ وللا كان كل الناس يقدرون؟
سواءً برًّا أو بحرًا
تاريخ العرب مليء بالشعر، هذا رقم واحد
رقم اثنين، الشعر
رقم ثلاثة، الشعر ثم التاريخ
فالشعر والتاريخ والأنساب والعلوم هذه الإنسانية
ما أعطت فرصة أن يُنقل لنا من علماء الفلك
أتكلم في الجزيرة العربية، من علماء الفلك أو علماء الطقس
أو حتى الفلاحين والمزارعين المشهورين
هذا إذا كان لهم كتابات في الزراعة وفي الري
أو في العمارة كمهندسين أو في فنون أخرى
فالعرب أوقاتهم مُلئت ببعض الفنون للإنسانية
فكانت على حساب فنون أخرى
فما أستطيع أقول لك بوقت الجاهلية
أن هذا يشار له بالبنان، أنه عالم بالفلك أو بالأرصاد أو بالزراعة
أو حتى مثل «ابن ماجد» مثلًا بالبحار
أتكلم عن وسط الجزيرة العربية ما أذكر شيء
أما في العصور المتأخرة، كمثلًا «العيوني» و«راشد الخلاوي»
الله يغفر له ويرحمه وتوفي حديثًا الدكتور «صالح العجيري» في الكويت
فيه أسماء لا بأس فيها
ومعظمهم يشتغلون في مسألة الطوالع والنجوم
ومسائل محدودة لا يتجازونها لعلوم أخرى، والله أعلم
أيش علاقة علم الفلك بعلم الأرصاد؟
سؤال جميل، وهذا يخطئ فيه الإعلام
سواءً كان المقروء أو المسموع
عندما يقولون: فلكي يتنبأ بحالة مطرية قادمة
فلكي ذكر كذا كذا، ما له علاقة
الفلك شيء، والأرصاد شيء
هذا علم يختلف عن هذا العلم
هذا له مناهجه وله تطبيقاته، وهذا علم آخر
أول قبل الكليات وقبل الجامعات قديمًا
عندما يبرز الإنسان بالعلوم الطبيعية؛ غالبًا يكون موسوعي
فيتحدث في الطقس والمناخ، ويتحدث في الزراعة
يتحدث حتى في الطب بالمناسبة بعضهم
ويتحدث بأمور للفلك، موسوعي
لأن المسائل هذه الكتب فيها، أو المخطوطات
ربما أربعة، خمسة، ستة تحصلها في المدينة الفلانية
فيمكن يستوعبها
أما الآن علميًا ما يجوز أن نقول: فلكي يتوقع أمطار أو برد أو حر
فلكي يتحدث عن الكسوف، الخسوف، العبور، الشهب، النيازك
جيولوجي يتكلم عن الزلازل، البراكين، التصدعات، عن الحرّات
الأرصاد يتحدث فقط عن الغلاف الجوي
ماذا عن الجغرافي؟ الجغرافي مثل النحلة
الجغرافي له أن يتحدث في هذه الأمور
لكن ليس بعمق المتخصص
بمعنى درس الغلاف الجوي متمثلًا بالجغرافية المناخية
درس الغلاف الصخري متمثلًا بالجمورفولوجيا والتضاريس
درس أيضًا الجانب للبيئي والتربة
جغرافية التربة، الجغرافية البيئية، جغرافية النباتات وما شابه ذلك
فتجد أن الجغرافي يتميز بالموسوعية التي ورثناها من قبل
وهذه تحمّل الجغرافي أن يكون أكثر قراءة واطلاع
علشان يأخذ من علم الجيولوجيا ومن علم الميثولوجيا
ومن علم البيديولوجيا وأيضًا علم الانثروبولوجيا
فكلها على أكتاف الجغرافية هذه
وبالمناسبة هناك مقررات في كل هذه الفنون
يدرسها طالب الجغرافيا
وهذا تجعل الجغرافي مقدم على غيره بناءً على التجربة
وليس تحيزًا لتخصصي، في مسألة تفسير الظواهر الطبيعية
مسألة -سلمك الله- التخطيط للمدن أو التخطيط لمشاريع معينة
لأنه آخذ من كل بحر قطرة
فيفهم بالأمور هذه، بالذات فيما يتعلق بالمناخ
عندنا شيء اسمه المناخ التطبيقي
ما نتحدث مثل الأرصاد، فقط عن درجات الحرارة
وعن الكتلة الهوائية وعن الرياح والغبار وما شابه ذلك
لا، نتجاوز هذه المرحلة مع فهمنا لهذا
أنا أعترف ليس فهمًا كعمق أهل الأرصاد
لكن أخذنا ما فيه الكفاية ونربط هذا بالأمراض
نفسّر الأمراض المرتبطة بالتقلبات الجوية
نحدد أوقات الزراعة بناءً على الأحوال الجوية
نحدد أوقات الدراسة، أوقات السياحة، أوقات الكشتات
نحدد أمور كثيرة
وأيضًا اللبس، أيضًا عملية العزل والبناء وطريقة البناء
لأننا درسنا فلك ودرسنا مناخ
ودرسنا أيضًا أمور تتعلق بالسكان
ودرسنا أيضًا التربة بما فيها بالنبات وما فوقها من حيوانات
فالمفترض ما نأخذ التنبؤات الطقس من الفلكيين؟
لا، والفلكيين ما يتنبؤون
الفلكيين اللي متخرجين من كلية العلوم قسم الفلك
غالبًا أناس ما يتعاطون هذه الأمور
وليس تخصصهم إلا في حالة واحدة
عندما يكون الفلكي عنده هواية رديف
فيتنبأ بناءً على هوايته وليس بناءً على دراسته للفلك
لما يجي الآن يقولون لك: أن السنوات الأخيرة صار هو أكثر حر
أو بعضهم برضه يجي يقول لك: أن السنوات الأخيرة صار أكثر برودة
من وين يجيبون هذه المعلومات وكيف يقدرون؟
الأرصاد عندنا قديمة نسبيًّا
وبعض المدن مثل الرياض على سبيل المثال
ممكن تحصل سجل مناخي لأكثر من خمسين سنة، تقريبًا من السبعينيات
معظم المطارات من السبعينيات الميلادية
تذهب إلى «أرامكو» في الشرقية ممكن أقدم من هذا بعشرين سنة
فتحصّل سجلات مناخية
هذه السجلات المناخية نقارن درجة الحرارة على سبيل المثال
في الرياض من عام 1970 إلى عام 2020
سوف تجد أن درجة الحرارة طالعة ترند ومرتفعة
بمعدل نصف درجة المتوسط كل عقد
كل عشر سنوات؛ درجة الحرارة ترتفع
ليس في الرياض وليس في الشرق الأوسط، في كل العالم
بما فيها اليابس والبحار والمحيطات
بما يسمى الاحترار العالمي
الاحترار العالمي هذا مشكلة يعاني منه كوكب الأرض
بما كسبت أيدي الناس بسبب التلوث
ودك نسميه ونتفق على مصطلح
التغيّر المناخي وللا الاحتباس الحراري وللا الاحترار العالمي؟
الاحترار العالمي أدى إلى التغيّر المناخي
فلما ارتفعت درجة الحرارة واحترّت الأجواء
بقية العناصر تأثرت بدرجة الحرارة
فالضغط الجوي راح يتغير
وإذا تغيّر الضغط الجوي، سرعة الرياح واتجاهها سوف يتغيّر
إذا أسرعت الرياح، كثافة الغبار وقوته سوف تتغيّر
أيضًا، مجيء السحب وكثافة السحب
بسبب ارتفاع درجة الحرارة وتسخين المحيطات
وارتفاع نسبة الرطوبة النسبية
ومن ثم تشكّل السحب سوف يتغيّر
لذلك سلوك الطقس في كل العالم تغيّر وأصبح أكثر عنفًا وأكثر تطرفًا
تسجل كتل البرد كثافةً وحجمًا شيء ما كنا نشاهده
الجفاف في بعض المواقع تكسّر الأرقام القياسية
الفيضانات في مناطق جافة مثل مناطقنا
تتميز بأنها مناطق شحيحة الأمطار
ومع ذلك يكون عندنا فيضانات
بسبب الاحترار العالمي الذي قاد إلى التغيّر المناخي
ومثل أيش الفيضانات اللي في منطقتنا؟
عندك الفيضان اللي صار عام 2009 في جدة
2011 في جدة وخلّف خسائر بالأرواح وخسائر بالممتلكات
حصل فيضانات أيضًا في الرياض، في بريدة
وادي «الرمة» في الموسم الماضي مشى مرتين
في حدث تاريخي من أندر ما يكون
بسبب غزارة الأمطار وكثافة وتردد الحالات المطرية
ممكن أحد يقول مثلًا لو تجاوزنا جدة
بما أن جزء من السيول اللي حصلت هو سوء في البنية التحتية
لكن لو أخذنا على أنه زيادة أمطار
فالناس بتقول هذا أنعم وأكرم به من تغيّر مناخي
وين المشكلة؟ بالعكس زيادة المطار، ومن لا يحب المطر؟
هذا يقودنا إلى سؤال
هل التغيّر المناخي إيجابي أم سلبي؟
الأغلب أن التغيّر المناخي وارتفاع درجة الحرارة سلبي على الإنسان
سوف تكون فاتورة الكهرباء أكثر، فاتورة المياه أكثر
انفعال الإنسان ونفسيته
سوف تكون أكثر انفعالًا بسبب ارتفاع درجة الحرارة
تخيل عام سبعين في حائل على سبيل المثال
لا تصل درجة الحرارة 40 إلا أربعة أو خمسة أيام أو أسبوع بالكثير
الآن تتجاوز الـ 45 شهرين وشوي
وقس على ذلك في مناطق المملكة وغير المملكة
هذه من السلبيات
لا يعني ذلك أن التغيّر المناخي سيجعلنا نتكدس في المنازل
ونرفع من طاقة التكييف ونحلّ الموضوع
أنت حلّيت الموضوع كإنسان، لكن حيواناتك حلالك
حتى الحلال الآن يحتاج إلى مضلات
حتى الأبل تشوفهن أحيانًا يتزاحمن تحت ظل محدود
في شجرة فريدة ويتيمة في صحراء قاحلة
تشوف الطيور والحمام صافات على ظل عمود الكهرب
ما تتحمل هذه الدرجة العالية، فيقضي على بعض الأنواع
سواءً من حشرات أو من حيوانات مستأنسة
وربما أنت، إذا كان عندك مشروع، ممكن أيضًا تخسر
أو عطاءه ومخرجاته تتأثر بارتفاع درجة الحرارة
أما إذا نزلنا للنباتات والمزارع وإلى المشاريع الزراعية
ستستهلك النباتات والمحاصيل مياه أكثر
وهذا سوف يؤثر على المياه الجوفية
وسوف يرفع الفاتورة على المزارع ثم على المستهلك بالنهاية
هذا على افتراض أن المحصول وصل لك سالم
لفحة الشمس وارتفاع درجة الحرارة لها أمراضها الخاصة
والمحاصيل لها سقف علوي في التحمل
إذا ارتفع؛ فسدت
فتضطر إلى عمل البيوت المحمية أو الصوب الزراعية
واستخدام مناخ صناعي عملية التبريد، وهذا مُكلف
وهذا هو التوجه اللي صاير في البلد
أضف إلى ذلك حتى مواسم الدراسة
سيدخل في مجال حار جدًّا بدايته ونهايته
حتى مواسم السياحة سوف تتقلص، مواسم أيضًا السفر
كثير من الناس عندهم حدائق وبساتين ما يقدرون يطلعون برّا
اللي يمكن ثمانية أشهر يقول أنا ما أستفدت من حديقتي
نظرًا لارتفاع درجة الحرارة حتى في الليل
توصل في الليل إلى 39 أو 40
يعني ناوي تضع مكيف في الخارج عشان تتأقلم مع درجة الحرارة
من الإيجابيات في هذا السياق
ممكن على مستوى المملكة العربية السعودية
أنها تزود الأمطار بنسبة تقدر 15% تزود أو تنقص
ولو أكيد أن بعض النماذج يعطي النتائج سلبية
أو لا يوجد تغيّر، وبعض النماذج يوجد تغيّر
بل هذا قادني إلى تفسير الحديث
عندما قال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
«لا تقوم الساعة حتى تعود أرض العرب مروجًا وأنهارًا»
كيف سوف تعود أرض العرب مروجًا وأنهارًا؟
عبر أي سيناريو؟
ذكرت عدة سيناريوهات، من ضمنها أنا لا أتزم فيه
ولكنه يبقى باب مفتوح وسيناريو مفتوح
ربما العبث الذي أحدثه الإنسان خلال السبعين عقد الماضية
عندما لوّث ونشر غازات الدفيئة
على وجه التحديد ثاني أكسيد الكربون وغاز الميثان
ممكن التغيّر المناخي يقود أرض العرب والشرق الأوسط
إلى أن تنزل عليهم الأمطار في فترة الصيف
كما حصل في الصيف قبل العام
فنزلت علينا أمطار لدرجة أن الباذر وبعض النباتات
بدأت تظهر في الأرض في الصيف
وانخفضت درجة الحرارة
ووصلت الأمطار ليس فقط في الربع الخالي
لأنها قادمة من الجنوب بالمناسبة
النظام يختلف عن الشتاء في الصيف
تأتينا بوابة الجنوب، بوابة بحر العرب
تدفع الكتل الرطبة كما كانت أرض العرب قبل 7 آلاف سنة
الأمطار الصيفية جنوبية المصدر
وصلت إلى تبوك قبل العام
الله سبحانه وتعالى أرانا نموذج مصغر وقصير
من مناخ أرض العرب قبل 7000، 8000 - 10000 سنة
وهي الفترة التي أشار لها النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
طبعًا فيه دكتور جولوجيا، الدكتور «عبدالله العمري»
كان يقول: أن هو بحث الربع الخالي بالكامل
وما وجد أي أثر لأنهار أو شيء من هذا القبيل
لكن هو نقاش طويل
بس الحين إذا في المنطقة عندنا بتزيد الأمطار
هل هو سلبي بالنسبة لنا؟
إذا هو إيجابي بالنسبة لنا، ليش نتعامل مع تغيّر المناخ ونحلّه؟
فإذا الأمطار بتصير عندنا أكثر
مفترض أن السعودية تكون مبسوطة بالتغيّر المناخي
ومفترض أنها ما تشتغل على أي مشروع يقلل من حرارة...
كما ذكرت لك هذا احتمال ونسبي بسيط ربما ما يحصل
كندا على سبيل المثال إيجابي ارتفاع درجة الحرارة
وشمال روسيا، شمال أوربا
فارتفاع درجة الحرارة سوف يخفف عليهم وطأة الشتاء المزعجة
يخفف عليهم الفاتورة
عندنا تزود، عندهم تنقص
أيضًا تتسع نطاق المحاصيل الزراعية
التي لا يمكن أن تستنبت بعض المحاصيل في أجواء باردة
الآن ارتفعت درجة الحرارة؛ فرصة أنك تنافس الجنوبيين
وتبدأ بزراعة بعض المحاصيل
أيضًا راح نخسر احنا بعض المحاصيل
اللي ما نستطيع أن نزرعها بسبب ارتفاع درجة الحرارة
ما أقدر أحدد محصول معين، لكن النخلة على سبيل المثال
يمكن حدها علشان تثمر
دعنا من النمو، تنمو حتى في الشام وتركيا وأجزاء من جنوب أوربا
لكن علشان تثمر تحتاج إلى حرارة متجمعة كبيرة وتحتاج إلى حرارة
فالتغيّر المناخي والاحترار سوف يدفع نطاق النخلة إلى الشمال
فيبدأ الشماليين، بالذات في العراق وسوريا
وأيضًا الأردن، فلسطين، لبنان، فضلًا عن تركيا في المستقبل طبعًا
يبدأ التمر مثل اللي عندنا بسبب ارتفاع درجة الحرارة
لكن باختصار التغيّر المناخي
سلبياته -والله أعلم- أكثر من إيجابياته
سبب بسيط أنك أنت أيها الإنسان
تدخّلت في تركيبة الغلاف الجوي
المتمثلة بالعناصر الغازية الموجودة في الغلاف الجوي
احنا نقول أنها زادت بنسبة 1% درجة مئوية واحدة، صح؟
فإذا درجة مئوية واحدة، أيش اللي يخلي حائل
من أربع أيام إلى أن توصل شهرين متواصلة من الحرارة؟
درجة مئوية واحدة تسوي كل هذا؟!
أبو عمر إذا قلنا درجة مئوية واحدة على مستوى العالم الآن
هذا الكلام حول المتوسط السنوي العالمي
لكن تسوي تركيز على الرياض على سبيل المثال
الدرجة ذي المئوية راح ترفع درجة الحرارة الكبرى المعتادة 45 أو 46
إلى أنك تذوق الـ 49 و 50، أسبوع أو أسبوعين
وإذا استمرت أو استمر العبث بالمناخ بهذا الشكل
بسبب التلوث من المصانع والقطارات والسيارات بل وحتى الطائرات
وسوف نضيف غازات دفيئة أكثر
مثل اللي يلبس ثوب ثم فوقه ثوب ثم ثالث ورابع
سوف يشعر بالحر والضجر والتعرّق
الأرض نفس الشيء؛ جالسين نلبسها عدة طبقات
من الغازات الدفيئة التي تمنع خروج الأشعة الحرارية
التي قدرها الله سبحانه وتعالى أن تذهب إلى الفضاء
ويكون عندنا فقط جزء يدفينا والباقي يروح للفضاء
الآن اللي يخرج فيه نسبة معينة يتم منعه وحجبه
بسبب ارتفاع نسبة ثاني أكسيد الكربون
فترفع عندك درجة الحرارة
إن استمر الوضع بالشكل ذا كما ذكرت في لقاء سابق
ربما نصل إلى بحر الـ 60
والآن سجلنا 54 في العراق أكثر من مرة
وسجلنا 52 و 53 في الكويت في فصول صيفية ماضية
الخمسينات أصبحت طبيعية في المنطقة
ربما بعد عقدين أو ثلاثة عقود
نصل إلى هذه الدرجة المزعجة والمحرجة
وأيضًا الممرضة في الواقع لنا كإنسان وأيضًا الحيوان والنبات
إلا أن يشاء الله سبحانه وتعالى وتتغير الأمور بصورة أو بأخرى
ليش دائمًا يقولون أن فيه 97% من العلماء
هم اللي متفقين على وجود فعلًا التغيّر المناخي
ففيه 3% لا يرون بالتغيّر المناخي
النسبة هذه والاختلاف هذا مو موضوع التغيّر المناخي
الآن عندنا تغيّر مناخي وهذا يتفق عليه كثير من الناس
أن فيه تغيّر مناخي
اللي ما اتفقنا؛ السبب
من هو السبب التغيّر المناخي؟
الـ 3% يقولون لا
سبق أن الأرض ارتفعت درجة الحرارة
أعلى مما هي عليها الآن، وهذا صحيح بالمناسبة
ودورات تدور حول الأرض
وسبب الارتفاع هذا ليس بشري وإنما طبيعي
بعضهم يعوزه إلى الشمس وهي بريئة
وبعضهم يعوزه إلى أمور في كوكب الأرض
وأن الإنسان بريء من هذا، وأن وراء «الأكمة» ما وراءها
والغرب على وجه التحديد والدوائر الغربية العلمية مع السياسية
تحاول ضرب منتجي النفط على وجه التحديد الخليج
عندما يقولون: أن سبب ارتفاع درجة الحرارة
النفط وإحراق الوقود الإحفوري
وهؤلاء في الواقع تغافلوا وغفلوا عن إحراق
ومازالوا في الولايات المتحدة وفي أوربا
وعادوا بعد حرب أوكرانيا
إلى استخدام الفحم في توليد الطاقة الكهربائية
وهي أشد فتكًا بالغلاف الجوي، وهم أكثر منا استخدام للنفط
وهم الدول الصناعية، هم الذين يصنعون
وبالتالي لا تُرمى التهمة على دول الخليج
وهذا الذي جعل بعض الناس ينكرون التغيّر المناخي
ويقولون أنه مؤامرة
في الواقع ليست مؤامرة بقدر ما أن الدوائر السياسية الغربية
يحسنون الركوب مع الأحداث ومع بعض الوقائع
ويوجهون الدفة لصالحهم
فالتغيّر المناخي صحيح
إذن نأخذ هذا الموضوع ونضرب بها أعدائنا
أو الذين ينافسوننا أو من أجل أن نبتزهم بكثير من الضرائب في هذا
فهذا أتفق معكم أن الدوائر الغربية
ركبت هذه الموجة ووجهت الموضوع لصالحها
لكن لا يعني ذلك أنك تنكر الاحترار اللي صاير والتغيّر المناخي
مسألة اللي سببه الإنسان أو الشمس
والطاقة الشمسية الواصلة أو غيره؛ هذا أمره هيّن
لكن دعنا نتفق أن فيه تغيّر مناخي
ويكفي 97%
بل حتى على مستوى الإدارة السعودية
عندما أوجدت مؤتمرات تتعلّق بالتغيّر المناخي
بل وعيّنت وزير الخارجية الأسبق «عادل الجبير»
المسؤول عن هذا الملف التغيّر المناخي
دلالةً على أن الإدارة السعودية مؤمنة بهذه المشكلة
والمسألة ليست مؤامرة كما يقولون
هناك وزارات، وزارة التغيّر المناخي في بعض الدول العربية
والكل يشتكي من هذا الموضوع
فهي حقيقة ملموسة ومقيوسة ومدروسة ومصورة أيضًا
فلا تقلق بشأن موضوع المؤامرة وما شابه ذلك، والله أعلم
الآن من الناس اللي يقولون أنه مو بالإنسان
ناس معتبرين حازوا على جوائز «نوبل» وغيرها
فاللي يقولون أن هذا جزء طبيعي من دورة حياة الكرة الأرضية
إذا كان طبيعي فأكيد أن ما نقدر نغيّر أي شيء
يوم يكون طبيعي قبل مئات السنين وآلاف السنوات
ما كان بهذه السرعة
الآن التغيّر سريع جدًّا في غضون سبع عقود
وسبع عقود بدأ مع الثورة الصناعية
وبالمناسبة أخطر وأشد الدول في التلويث
هي الصين، ثم الولايات المتحدة، ثم روسيا، ثم الهند
بل أن صور الأقمار الصناعية المتخصصة في مراقبة جودة الهواء
تثبت أن الصين كأنها بؤرة المدخنة أو شكوان سيارة
شيء مهول جدًّا
يا أخي يكفي أنك تتأمل طائرة «777 بوينق»
تمشي من الرياض إلى نيويورك
كم ستحرق في طبقات الجو العليا من الوقود الخاص بالطائرات؟
كم تتوقع؟
ثلاث إلى أربع تريلات
واو!
الآن موجود ومعلّق في السماء ما لا يقل عن 15 ألف طيارة
إذا نزلت الطائرة؛ أقلعت الأخرى
تخيل 15 ألف طائرة فوق القارات الخمس
وفوق البحار والمحيطات على مدى 24 ساعة
سبعة أيام، ثلاثين يوم، 365 يوم في السنة
على مدى أكثر من عشرين سنة
وتزود ما بين الطائرات المدنية وعسكرية
ما بين طائرات ركاب وطائرات شحن
طائرات خاصة وطائرات تجارية
شيء مهول وتُحرق هذه الغازات
أكيد سوف تغيّر من المركبات
وأكيد أن السبب هو الإنسان
واحنا غفلنا عن المصانع، غفلنا عن قطع الغابات
غفلنا عن السيارات
كم من عشرات الآلاف يوميًا تنزل من السيارات الجديدة في الأسواق
فهذا دليل واضح وملموس ومقيوس
وما لهم مصلحة العلماء يكذبون بالمناسبة
يكذبون عشان ماذا؟ ما لهم مصلحة؟
علشان مثلًا يبتزوننا بشيء معين وكذا
الموضوع واضح جدًّا وهناك مراكز علمية مستقلة
ومراكز شرقية بالمناسبة
وعلماء مسلمين اشتغلوا في الموضوع هذا
ثم هذا أمر حتى نجده في البيانات السعودية
بيانات الطقس والمناخ
في السجلات اللي ذكرنا خمسين سنة
نجد فيها فعلًا التغيّر واضح جدًّا
بينما ما شفنا أي بركان انفجر في المنطقة
ما شفنا أي تغيّر في الطاقة الشمسية القادمة من الشمس
ما شفنا أي تغيّر في التيارات البحرية
ما شفنا أي تغير كبير على مستوى القارات والمحيطات والبحار
حتى تقول أن الإحترار العالمي سببه تغيّر في الأرض
الأرض ما صار فيها تغيّر
اثبت لي إذا فيه تغيّر بسيط، ما فيه
حتى الشمس بالمناسبة عليها مراقبة شديدة
من مراصد فلكية وموجودة عبر الإنترنت
تشوف الشمس بالصورة ومصوّرة
ودرجة الحرارة والطاقة الكهرومغناطيسية القادمة من الشمس
وكل صغيرة وكبيرة في الشمس
لو كانت الشمس هي السبب
لتضح الموضوع وأعلنوها العلماء
ليش يخفون الموضوع هذا؟
طيب هل الدور الآن اللي يحل المشكلة
هو على الأفراد وللا الحكومات؟
لو افترضنا أن حكومة أرادت أن تحل الموضوع هذا، ما تستطيع لوحدها
كوكب الأرض متصل والغلاف الجوي واحد
لذلك لو أتى الدولة وقلبت بيوم وليلة
السيارات إلى أن تكون كهربائية
تخيل الطائرات كهربائية وهي لن تكون طبعًا، لكن خلنا نتخيل
طائرات كهربائية وسيارات كهربائية وأيضًا الطاقة الشمسية
أو طاقة الرياح أو طاقة الكهرومائية
وقفلت كل المصانع التقليدية
هل ستسلم من التغيّر المناخي؟ لن تسلم
طيب جيرانك، الهواء مشترك، والكتل الهوية مشتركة
لذلك بريطانيا وأوربا وعلى وجه التحديد هولندا
مضوا بخطوات متقدمة في هذا السياق
واستخدموا الطاقة البديلة، الطاقة المتجددة
طاقة الرياح والطاقة الشمسية
وحرصين جدًّا بل وصلوا إلى مرحلة الوسواس
بمسألة التلوث من المصانع ومن السيارات
لكن لا يعني ذلك أنهم سيسلمون
من تلويث الصين أو الولايات المتحدة أو الهند
أو روسيا أو حتى البرازيل لأن أجواءنا واحدة
لا بد من تنمية الوعي من قِبل الحكومات
من قِبل المؤسسات والمراكز العلمية العالمية والعربية والسعودية
في هذا الموضوع عبر المدارس
أهمية ما قدّر الله سبحانه وتعالى في هذه الأرض
الله سبحانه وتعالى يقول «وَكُلُوا وَاشْرَبُوا وَلَا تُسْرِفُوا»
«وَلَا تُفْسِدُوا فِي الْأَرْضِ بَعْدَ إِصْلَاحِهَا»
4.6 مليار سنة والله سبحانه وتعالى
يجهّز الأرض لبني البشر
قبل أن يأتي آدم مر على الأرض 4.6 مليار سنة
حتى يهيئ هذا الكوكب الأزرق الفريد الجميل
الذي لا يوجد مثله حتى الآن
ثم جاء آدم عليه السلام وجاءت ذرية آدم متكامل لا تفسد فيه
لكن الإنسان أفسد خلال العقود السبعة الأخيرة
وصار ما صار
فلا بد أن هذه الرسالة الشرعية البيئية تصل إلى النشء
من أجل أن يستخدم الموارد اللي وهبها الله سبحانه وتعالى
وقدرها في الأرض باقتصاد
شرعيًا أكله وشربه ولبسه وسيارته
تخيل نركب سيارات 400 حصان، 600 حصان
الآن بعض السيارات الكهربائية تصل إلى 900، 1100
حتى فورملا ما هي الـ 1100
سيارات فخمة وسيارات عائلية وما يركبها إلا واحد
هنا فيه إسراف
السيارة الوحدة كم كلفتنا من شجرة؟
كم كلفتنا من ماء؟ كم كلفتنا من حيوان؟ أخذنا جلده وأخذنا مادته
كم كلفتنا من بترول؟ وكم سوف تؤثر على الأرض؟
فلو أخذنا هذه الآية كأيقونة لنا وكفنارة ومنارة
«وَكُلُوا وَاشْرَبُوا وَلَا تُسْرِفُوا»
وقوله سبحانه وتعالى «وَلَا تُفْسِدُوا فِي الْأَرْضِ بَعْدَ إِصْلَاحِهَا»
تعبدًا لله سبحانه وتعالى في كل ما نتعطاه حولنا
أنا أشوف هذا هي الخطوة الأولى
لأن المستقبل ليس لنا وإنما للأجيال القادمة
فلا بد أن تستشعر هذا الشعور
أذكر كنت في السيارة في أجزاء من سويسرا
وجالسين ناكل وجبة بسيطة أنا والعائلة
الجو إلى حدٍ ما دافئ
أنا مشغّل المكيف وجالسين في السيارة
فجأة قُرعت النافذة من رجل سويسري مُسن
قال لي كذا، أغلق السيارة
شوف الشعور المتقدم
وبكل احترام، أغلق السيارة
جالسين أنتم ما راح تستخدمون السيارة؛ رجاءً لا تلّوث
مع أن الأمر بسيط جدًّا، لا تلّوث
هنا نستطيع أبو عمر نزرعه في قلوب النشء القادم
عبر المناهج وعبر وسائل الإعلام
وسوف نصل بإذنه تعالى نحن واليابانيين
والأرجنتين والأستراليين والبرازليين في المستقبل بإذنه تعالى
يجي الفرد أو أي حد يقول: أن فعلًا دوري أنا غير مهم
ممكن أن أروح بدل ما آخذ كيس بلاستيك
أروح أشيل شنطتي وأحط فيه أغراضي
وللا بدل ما يأخذ مزازة؛ أشرب في كأس
وأروح أسوي إعادة تدوير وغيره
بس أن دوره غير مهم ولم يغيّر شيء
لطالما أن المصانع لا تزال موجودة والطائرات بهذا الشكل
أنا كفرد ما لي قيمة في حل المشكلة التغير المناخي
بعض الشباب الآن سعوديين وصلوا إلى هذا المستوى من الوعي
بدأ يصير معهم أكياس يعاد استخدامها أكثر من مرة
يروح البقالة معه كيسه أو ملقحه
بدأ لا يتعاطى مياه القوارير التي ترمى
وإنما يأخذ الكاس اللي يحفظ البرودة ويشربه
ذهبت إلى دول تُعد من دول العالم الثالث
ما يعطونك البلاستيك
يعطونك الكيس اللي مصنوع من مادة بأسبوع تحت الشمس وتنتهي
وأيضًا تدفع عليها
بينما عندي هنا يعطينا الزبادي بكيس والبيبسي بكيس
والخبز بكيس والصابون بكيس
ويضاعف الكيس
إيه نعم، وإذا قضى ثلاثة أكياس على دربنا
فهذه راح تنتهي
أنا أعتقد أن الحكومات هي التي تسن القوانين
وهي اللي تخلي الناس تتغير
أما أنا كفرد دوري في التغيّر المناخي هامشي
فيه طائفة وفيه مجموعة بيئية سعودية
ما كانوا يحتطبون ولا يقطعون الأشجار
قبل ما تُسن الأنظمة الأخيرة الجميلة والرائعة
والتي جعلتنا في مصاف الدول المتقدمة
فيما يتعلّق بالتعاطي مع البيئة
لكن أول وهم ليسوا بقلّة، ما كانوا يؤذون البيئة
سواءً كانت أشجار أو رمال أو حيوانات أو طيور
أو حتى غدران ومياه
كانوا يتعاملون مع هذه المقدرات تعامل شرعي
وهذا جمال وروعة الدين
أنه أدبنا كيف نتعامل حتى مع الحيوان
حتى مع الهواء، حتى مع النار
بل لاحظ يقول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
«إذا قامت الساعة وفي يد أحدكم فسيلة؛ فليغرسها»
شعار صناعة الحياة في ظل وجود أجواء
ربما تكون الساعة؛ فليغرسها
إذا أخذت غصن يؤذي المسلمين؛ لك أجر عظيم جدًّا
بل من قطع سدرة صوّب رأسه في النار
العمل نشوفه بسيط جدًّا
لكن الشرع رتب على هذا الاعتداء على البيئة
أو حتى على الحيوان أو قتل الهرّة
بل ضرب الله سبحانه وتعالى لنا عبر الحديث
بحيوان لا يمكن أن أقول لك اسمه
إلا عندما أقول الله يكرمكم، كلب
الكلب، دخلت بغي من بني إسرائيل الجنة
بسبب أنها أعطت هذا الكلب جرعة من المياه
جمال وروعة الإسلام التي أتمنى أن تترجم لكل اللغات
فيما يتعلق بالبيئة على وجه التحديد
سوف تبهر هؤلاء اللي عندهم هوس في البيئة
خاصةً الأوربيين والأستراليين
فيما يتعلق كيف نتعاطى
بل هناك فيه أحاديث بالمناسبة مترجمة وموضوع في الفنادق
«لا تُسرف ولو كنت على نهرٍ جار»
فهذه قد تكون بوابة إلى أن يُسلم غير المسلم
والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول
«إن الله لينزع بالسلطان ما لا ينزع بالقرآن»
أحيانًا التعاليم الدينية ما تكون رادعة لبعض الناس
فيأتي السلطان عبر التعليمات والأنظمة
ومن ثم يلتزم الناس فيتطابق توجيه ولي الأمر مع التوجيه الشرعي
فيكون نور على نور
فهذه جميلة ورائعة
فدعونا نبدأ نحن كأفراد فيما يتعلق بقناعاتنا بالتغيّر المناخي
وأرى أن المستقبل قريب جدًّا
في محاولة الحد من عملية تلويث الماء أو التربة أو الهواء
وأنظمة أيضًا سُنت وأعلنت في هذا السياق ولله للحمد
نحن نعيش مرحلة ذهبية في هذا السياق ولله الحمد
أيش أثر زراعة الأشجار على التغيّر المناخي؟
فاليوم عندنا مثلًا الرياض الخضراء
أو السعودية الخضراء أو هذه المشاريع
هل تساهم في تقليل درجة الحرارة؟
إذا خرجت من الحي واتجهت إلى منطقة ريفية ومزارع
لاحظ درجة الحرارة في السيارة ستنخفض
وأحيانًا يكون الفرق ما بين الحي الخرساني والمزارع
وما بينهما ربما كيلو إلى خمس أو ست درجات خاصةً في المساء
وذي عدد كبير ودرجة كبيرة
وفرق كبير ما بين الحي وبين المزارع
لذلك جميل أن نُطعّم الأرصفة والمنازل بهذه الأشجار
وعبر مشاريع حكومية كبيرة جدًا
على مستوى مشروع الرياض الخضراء
وهو من أفضل المشاريع في هذا السياق
مر علينا تذكر ما يسمى بأسبوع الشجرة
إلى أربعين سنة والرقعة الزراعية أو الأشجار والتشجير بتراجع
والدليل على ذلك، لو تشاهد مدارسنا قبل ثلاثين أو أربعين سنة
ما تشوف المبنى من الأشجار
وتشوف البلديات، وبعض الجهات الحكومية والشوارع كأنها غابة
ثم بدأنا بالرجوع
حتى هيّأ الله سبحانه وتعالى لنا هذه الرؤية المباركة
فبدأنا بعملية التشجير والتخضير على مستوى كبير جدًّا
10 مليار شجرة بإذنه تعالى
سوف تزرع في غضون العقود القادمة
المشروع سوف يبدأ عام 2024 -2030
ستزرع بإذنه تعالى وفقًا لخارطة الطريق المتعلقة بهذا الموضوع
حوالي 900 مليون شجرة
وتم الآن زراعة ما يقرب من 40 مليون شجرة تقريبًا
فنحن ذاهبون بهذا الاتجاه
سؤالك هل سوف تغيّر؟
نعم، ستغير النفسيات، وسوف تغير من درجة الحرارة
وكلما كثفت الأشجار حول منزلك، حول مسجدك
استراحتك، والشوارع والميادين
كلما حصلت على انخفاض أكثر في درجة الحرارة
كم الدرجة؟ لا أستطيع أن أحدد لأنها تختلف كثافة الأشجار
لازم أن نبالغ وأن نكثف هذه الأشجار
فهي خير وبركة لنا وللطيور ولدرجة الحرارة
ويكفي أنها تصفّي وتنقّي لنا الأجواء
وتعطينا مزيدًا من الأكسجين
أنت تقول تتغير درجة الحرارة من مكان إلى آخر
حتى لو كان على كيلو
هو سؤال الارتباط فيه ضئيل، لكن ودي أعرف
ليش تتغير درجة الحرارة بين الظهر والعصر
وتزداد درجة الحرارة، رغم أن الظهر تكون الشمس فيه أعلى؟
فيصير العصر دائمًا أشد حرارة
هذه اللي أقراه في السيارة عندي
إذا طلعت مثلًا تصلي الظهر؛ أنت تواجه أشعة الشمس
التي هي في سمت السماء، في سمت القبة السماوية
يعني فوق راسك تقريبًا
والأرض أيضًا حصلت على درجة حرارة كافية
من شروق الشمس إلى الساعة 12:00
لكن إذا طلعت تصلي مثلًا العصر
وأنا أركّز على موضوع صلاة الناس
يمشي فيستشعر خلاف اللي بالسيارة يستشعر
راح يقابلك العصر درجة حرارة
أو التسخين الأرضي أشد من التسخين الشمسي
لأن الأرض أخذت ساعات زيادة حتى تصل إلى القمة
ولذلك درجة الحرارة العظمى متى تسجل؟
ما بين الساعة 2:00 ظهرًا إلى 4:00
وأنت ماشي العصر، راح تواجهك الشمس
وإن كانت مالت قليلًا فأصبحت أقل من الظهر
لكن الأرض أكثر من الظهر والسموم
الهواء خلاص تشبّع من الحرارة؛ فيلفحك السموم
فتواجه ضيق وحرج العصر أكثر من الظهر
على التغيّر المناخي فيه واحدة من المشاكل
اللي الناس تتوقع أنها بتصير
اللي هي تزيد نسبة المياه في المحيطات والبحار
وبهذا تغرق بعض المدن
فالظاهر أن في فلوريدا وميامي
جالسين يزيدون ارتفاع الشواطئ أو الحدود البحرية
علشان المياه صارت تدخل جوّا المدينة
السؤال، هل ممكن تتأثر المدن البحرية في السعودية؟
سواءً جدة أو الدمام في الشرق وللا في الغرب؟
مثل ما تفضلت، التغيّر المناخي سوف يذوّب الجليد
في القطبين، فضلًا عن قمم الجبال
لكن بركز على القطبين، لأن المساحة كبيرة جدًّا
الآن الجليد يتراجع ويذوب
ويرتفع مستوى سطح البحر، هذا جانب
جانب آخر، إذا ارتفعت درجة حرارة الماء؛ يتمدد فيزيائيًّا
فعندي شغلتين هنا
من هنا سوف يرتفع مستوى سطح البحر في كل العالم
عندك الإسكندرية مرشحة، جزر الإمارات مرشحة
المالديف، كالكتا، نيويورك، هولندا، أجزاء من إسبانيا
كلها مرشحة أنها ستغرق
لكن السعودية والساحل الشرقي والغربي
لم يذكروا في تقرير علمي أن هناك مدن سوف تغرق
وما ذاك إلا أنها مرتفعة قليلًا، حتى لو ارتفعت خمسة متر كافي
حتى لو ارتفعت أربعة متر كافي
لكن هناك بعض الجزر وبعض المناطق يكون عند المد
أحيان يكون فيه مبالغة في المد بعض المناطق
هذه سوف تكتسح هذه الجزر أو هذه السواحل
فمن هنا تأتي المشكلة
وبالمناسبة، موضوع التغيّر المناخي
«بيل قيتس» فكر بفكرة مجنونة علشان يخفّض درجة الحرارة
ويكفينا من المخرجات السلبية وهي كثيرة للتغير المناخي
فكر أن يطلق «كربونات الكالسيوم»
طباشير، على هيئة دقيق وغبار
سوف يطلق صاروخ من أراضي السويد يبدو لي
سوف يطلق صاروخ على ارتفاعات تصل إلى تقريبًا تسعة عشر كيلو
ومن ثم ينثر هذه البودرة، ينثر هذا الغبار
بحيث أنه يحد من الأشعة الشمسية النافذة إلى الأرض
ومن ثم تنخفض درجة الحرارة
كأنه سحاب لكنه مرتفع وما تشاهده بالعين المجردة
لكن تشعر أن لسعة الشمس قليلة وكأنه مكسور عليها
طبعًا هذا عبث
هذا عبث لأنك لا تعلم عن النتائج
ولا يمكن أن تسوي نماذج ممكن تعطيك النتائج
لأن في الشتاء أيش بيكون مصيرنا؟
بالذات في شمال أوربا، سوف تنخفض درجة الحرارة أكثر
سوف تتمدد العواصف الثلجية أكثر
سوف تتغير مراكز الضغوط الجوية
فما ندري أيش اللي بيصير في النظام العالمي المناخي
بسبب هذا العبث المؤثر على افتراض ماذا؟
على افتراض أنه عمّمه على مستوى قارات
صدام حسين عندما فجّر الآبار الكويتية 700 بئر
فجّرها، والرياح الشمالية رياح «البوارح»
ساقت الدخان والسخام إلى أجواء المملكة وأجواء الخليج
خفّضت درجة الحرارة عندنا بشكل كبير
لدرجة أنك تجلس الظهر في أغسطس على الساحل الشرقي
وأنت ما تشعر بالأشعة الشمسية بسبب هذا الدخان
بل أن السخانات وتدفئة المياه مشغّلة في الكويت في عز الصيف
نظرًا للسواد العظيم
فأي عبث في المناخ بالشكل هذا
راح تكون نتائجه ربما سلبية
وهذا يقودنا إلى مقترح سعودي
تحت اسم «مروج» للأستاذ «صالح السديري»
والذي حاول أن يفكر بإعادة الأمطار الصيفية في أجواء السعودية
وإعادة البحيرات في القيعان
والمنخفضات والسبخات والأودية بملئها بالمياه
الطريقة طبعًا تطول
حتى يجلب الرطوبة وتتشكل السحب وتنزل الأمطار
وهو الآن بمرحلة عمل محاكاة لهذا النموذج
هل فعلًا سيستطيع هذا التدخل البشري المكلف
وأيضًا الكبير على مستوى شبه قارة
أن يعيد الأمطار صيفًا؟
أو على الأقل إن لم تتشكل السحب وتنزل الأمطار
على الأقل هل سيخفّض؟
لأن من أهدافه تخفيض درجة الحرارة
بطريقة غير التشجير وإنما بطريقة التبخير
ممكن أننا نعمل مثل المكيف الصحراوي
فالنتائج لم تخرج بعد وسوف تُرسل إلى ربما ثلاث مراكز عالمية
لعمل المحاكاة ومن ثم نتحدث إن شاء الله
ليش ما تشوفه عبث برضه؟
لأن هذا أرضي
وإن صدقت النظرية؛ هذا إيجابي للمنطقة
ولن يغيّر كثير من...
لأنك أنت ما تحكمت من المصدر
أنت ما رحت للشمس وقصرت عليها
لأن المصدر من الشمس
كل ما يجري في الغلاف الجوي
اللي يحركه بعد الله سبحانه وتعالى هذا النجم
ألا وهي الشمس
بينما أنت هنا مثل ما تسوي البخار هذا
أو ترش الأرض علشان يجيك براد
أو تشغّل مكيف عشان ويبرّدك
مو عبث بقدر أنك ما راح تغير المنطقة المحدودة
من أجل أنك تنبسط أو من أجل أنك تزرع
فالتغيير محدود في فكرة الأستاذ «صالح السديري»
لكن هل تنجح أو لا؟ هذا ننتظر نتيجة المحاكاة
أيش أثر سد «النهضة» على الأجواء في السعودية؟
اللي في أثيوبيا
بعد ما تم بناء السد، هو ربما تاسع سد في العالم
ضخم عملاق وكبير جدًّا
سيخلّف خلفه بحيرة «النهضة»
البعض يقول: أن مناخ المملكة وخاصة الجنوب الغربي
سيتغير وسوف تكثر الأمطار بسبب هذه البحيرة
نقول لهم المقياس جدًّا صغير
بحيرة «ناصر» أقرب للسعودية من «النهضة»
هذه تقريبًا بُعدها 500 كيلو
«النهضة» بُعدها 1,000 كيلو
بحيرة «ناصر» تقريبًا 5,000 كيلو متر مربع
خلف السد «العالي» جنوب مصر
بينما سد «النهضة» يصل تقريبًا إلى 240 ألف كيلومتر مربع
فـ 5000 مقابل النصف
البُعد 500 كيلو مقابل الضعف 1000 كيلو
ومع ذلك ما شفنا بحيرة «ناصر» لا جابت لنا سحب
ولا على مصر، ولا شيء من السودان
ولا على ينبع، ولا على أملج، ولا على المناطق المحيطة
فلا يوجد أثر لبحيرة وأن كانت كبيرة
لكن على مقياس البحر الأحمر، الخليج العربي
بحر العرب والمحيطات؛ يعتبر ولا شيء
مثل إنسان يقول أن الحديقة اللي فيها البحيرة جنوب الرياض
أن هذه الحديقة سوف تؤثر على مناخ الرياض
لا، لا يمكن، لا تمثل ولا واحد بالألف المساحة
فلا يمكن هذه المساحة البسيطة أن تؤثر على مناخ الرياض
حديقة الملك سلمان؟
حديقة الملك سلمان، هذه الرقعة الخضراء
التي سوف تحتل كل مساحة المطار القديم
بل وتعد أكبر حديقة صناعية في العالم
أكبر حديقة داخل مدينة في العالم
هذه الحديقة بإذنه تعالى سوف تنخفض درجة الحرارة
إذا خرجت من «الملز» مثلًا وللا «الروضة» وللا «السليمانية»
درجة الحرارة خلينا نقول مثلًا 40
ثم توسطت إلى حديقة الملك سلمان
سوف تنخفض ربما خمس درجات
شريطة أن لا يكثروا البناء
إذا كان فيه بناء ومسطحات مبنية أو ممرات بألوان داكنة
هنا سوف تعاني الأشجار التي سوف تخفض درجة الحرارة
أن عندي ألوان تمتص أشعة الشمس
وعندي مباني جالسة تشع علي حرارة
أو هناك أقواس حديدية والإكثار من عمل واستخدام الحديد
لأن الحديد تجلس إلى ساعتين، ثلاث ساعات بعد الغروب
وهو مثل الدفاية جالس يشع
فلو كانت الكتلة الخضراء هي الغالبة
ولتكن مثلًا 95% أو 97% من أرض الحديقة
بإذنه تعالى سوف تخفّض الحديقة
ويا حظ الأحياء القريبة والمتاخمة للحديقة
وعلى وجه التحديد «الربوة» والتي تقع إلى الجنوب من الحديقة
لسبب بسيط، أن الرياح السائدة الشمالية في الصيف
راح تكون شمالية
فراح تدفع الكتلة الرطبة والباردة الجاثمة فوق الحديقة إلى الجنوب
فأول حي يستقبله حي «الربوة»
تتوقع بيزود سعر المتر؟
أتوقع، هنا التوقعات مفترض
طيب آخر حاجة، فيه كثير منهم علماء أو رجال أعمال
اللي يرى بأن الكوكب مآله للدمار
ولذا تشوف مثلًا مشروع سواءً اللي تشغل عليه
«ناسا» أو حتى «سبيس إكس»
أن يكون في مكان آخر غير كوكب الأرض
واللي هو المريخ مثلًا
متشائمين بزيادة وللا منطقيين وواقعيين؟
جدًّا متشائمين
والله سبحانه وتعالى لم يخلق حسب علم العلماء
الذين اكتشفوا 4700 كوكب إلى الآن خارج نطاق المجموعة الشمسية
لم يكتشفوا أي كوكب مناسب إلى أن يكون فيه حياة أو سكن
خاصةً المجموعة الشمسية لا المريخ ولا غيره
مكلف جدًّا جدًّا، وإن وصلوا للمريخ في عام 2030 أو قريبًا من هذا
وكالة الفضاء الأمريكية «ناسا»
لأنهم شغالين الآن بتجارب ومحاكاة وشغل
إن وصلوا؛ سوف يعملون مستوطنات مغلقة
فيها حياة صناعية من إلى، وزراعة دقيقة جدًّا
والأمر هذا، أمر الكوكب سيبقى إلى قيام الساعة
والبشر سيبقون إلى قيام الساعة
ولن يكون هناك دمار شامل
حتى قبل 65 مليون سنة عندما رُجمت الأرض بنيزك عظيم كبير
هو الأكبر في السجلات التاريخية
ضرب المكسيك والجزء من خليج المكسيك
فقضى على 65% يقول العلماء من الحياة
وأبقى الله 25% ومنها الديناصورات بالمناسبة
أبقاها الله سبحانه وتعالى لنا حتى نرى هذه الفترة
«قُلْ سِيرُوا فِي الْأَرْضِ فَانظُرُوا كَيْفَ بَدَأَ الْخَلْقَ»
كلما تعمقت بهذه العلوم وبتاريخ الأرض
إيمانك يتعاظم، كيف أن الله سبحانه وتعالى
خلق هذا الكوكب بهذا الشكل، وهيئه لبني البشر
فلا يمكن أن الإنسان...
حتى لو أراد الإنسان أن ينتحر
وقاموا بضغطة زر واحدة
وفجّروا أكثر من تقريبًا 7000 قنبلة نووية
لن يموت كل الناس
وإن كان 70% 80% - 90%
وإن كان السيناريو هذا غير وارد
دعنا نقول إن جنوا، دعنا نقول أرادوا الانتحار
أو على افتراض «قرانددايزر»
جانا مخلوقات فضائية وأرادوا أن يحاربونا؛ لن يقضوا علينا
لأن الخريطة الشرعية وخريطة الطريقة القرآنية
أخبرتنا أننا سوف نبقى إلى قيام الساعة
وأخبرنا الله سبحانه وتعالى أن هناك
علامات صغرى لم تحصل إلى الآن
بعض العلامات الصغرى لم تحصل
وعشر علامات كبرى لم تقع
الإفساد قد يكون، زوال البشر سواءً عبر وباء مصنّع
حتى يقضو على 8 مليار إلى 3 مليار
ربما يصير هذا، نعم ممكن
كارثة كونية رجم من السماء ممكن
التغيّر المناخي ممكن أن يتفاقم
ونموت من شدة البرد أو الحر أو الجوع، الله أعلم
كل السيناريوهات هذه مفتوحة
سواءً كانت فضائية كونية أو أرضية
سواءً كانت طبيعية أو بشرية
كل السيناريوهات هذه مفتوحة
ولكن لن تقضي على البشر 100%
الله يعطيك العافية
الله يعافيك
شكرًا لكم
وشكرًا لعمر الشنقيطي وإيمن الحمادي وأسيل با عبدالله
لإعداد هذه الحلقة
والشكر كذلك لوهاب موسى خلف الكاميرات
وعبدالمجيد العطاس في التلوين
وفي التسجيل الصوتي عبدالعزيز المزي
والهندسة الصوتية محمد الحسن
وفي إدارة محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي نورة السبيعي
هذا فنجان أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع
ننشر كل الإنتاج بحب من مدينة الرياض
الأسبوع المقبل؛ ألقاكم
فيه سؤال صح نسيت
هو سؤال خارج الحلقة، ولكنها لطيفة
أنت تقول: أن الجوال ما يجذب الصواعق
يسجّل وللا لا؟ يدخل...
إيه
وأن السيارة أأمن من البيت، شلون؟
أولًا، إذا اشتريت أنت أي جهاز فيه كتالوج
الكاتالوج هذا من المصنع
من الصانع، من الخبراء، من العلماء
فيعطونك التنبيهات: لا تعمل، لا تسوي، ابعده عن الأطفال
لا تعرضه للشمس، لا تعرضه للرطوبة
لا ترص عليه ثلاث أو أربع كراتين
يعطيك التعليمات
عمرك شوفت بتعليمات الجوال
لا تستخدمه أثناء الصواعق والعواصف الرعدية؟
إذا قالوا الكلام هذا، معنى ذلك أن في كوالامبور
وللا في مانيلا، وللا في بروناي على سبيل المثال
أو جيزان
معنى ذلك أنه تمضي عليه نصف ساعة أو ساعة
معطل الجوال، وتعطلت مصالح الناس
فلا يوجد علاقة ما بين استخدام الجوال وما بين جذبه للصواعق
فإن ضربت الصاعقة الإنسان الذي يتحدث بالجوال
لا لأنه استخدم الجوال
ولكنه كان في المكان اللي قدّر الله سبحانه وتعالى أن تسقط الصاعقة
والدليل على ذلك أن الصاعقة تختار الإبل فتضربها بدون جوالات
الغنم بدون جوالات، الأشجار بدون جوالات
آباءنا وأجدادنا قبل الجوال تضربهم الصواعق
وحتى نطمئن أكثر الدول التي تعاني من كثرة العواصف الرعديّة
لا يعطّلون العمل بالجوال
ومع ذلك أنا عن نفسي
بالذات إذا كنت في منطقة الكهرباء فيها شديدة جدًّا
والصواعق شديدة جدًّا
لا أتجاسر، مع أني مؤمن أن ما له علاقة
حتى أتخلّص من الحديدة اللي معي بالمناسبة
إذا كنت في منطقة مرتفعة أو في البر وخالية
وأنا اللي قد أكون المفضلة للصاعقة
أتخلّص من المفاتيح، أتخلّص من الساعة، أتخلص من الجوال
واختبئ بالسيارة
أفضل شيء السيارة، حتى لو ضربت الصاعقة السيارة
سوف يتم التفريغ في الحديد
بس حاول أنك ما تمسك أي معدن
بعد السيارة، المنزل
وإذا كنت في المنزل، حاول أثناء العواصف الرعدية الشديدة
أن تفصل أجهزتك الكهربائية حتى ما تحترق
لأن ممكن الكهرباء ينزل عليك من الأسلاك العلوية
أو من مواصير الماء العلوية
ويضرب الشبكة عندك ويحرق عليك حتى اللوحة الأم حق الكمبيوتر
ولا تستخدم اللابتوب إلا فاصله من الكهرب
فأي شيء عندك غالي، أفصله من الكهرب
أيضًا لا تستحم أثناء العواصف الرعدية
لأن الصاعقة، لو سقطت فوق أعلى المنزل الخزان
سوف توصل الكهرباء عن طريق الماء
فلا تسبح
وبالمناسبة تعتبر جيزان أخطر وأكثف منطقة سعودية
تشهد كثرة العواصف الرعدية والصواعق
بل أنها تأتي إحصائيًّا قبل كل الدول الأوربية
نظرًا لموقعها الجغرافي شديدة الحرارة
والحرارة هذه هي التي بإذنه تعالى تصنع لنا
وتتشكل السحب الركامية
ومن ثم تتولد عندنا شرارة الكهرب
وموقعها يُأهّلها أن تكون أكثر رطوبة من غيرها
وأكثر حرارة، ووجود أيضًا الجبال
يلي ذلك الباحة، ثم عسير، ثم مكة، ثم المدينة
ثم القصيم ثم بقية المدن
لكن أعود مرة أخرى
مع ذلك لا تستخدم الجوال أثناء العواصف الرعدية